the past is a vast and mysterious land
that begins at the big bang and ends in
the present expanding with each passing
moment
it's the home of everything that came
before the key to understanding our
present
here we find the most amazing creatures
to ever roam our planet hundreds of
millions of species so diverse that our
imagination cannot do them justice
unfortunately the past carefully guards
its secrets
while there are a lot of things about
the past we know there are way more
things we know we don't know and worse
there are probably even more things we
don't even know that we don't know about
[Music]
think of the wonder of life
we now recognize about 1.5 million
eukaryotic species but there may be as
many as 10 million alive today
and although we are adding some 15 000
new species to our collective knowledge
each year the vast majority of life on
earth is still undiscovered
this is just what is around today
an estimated 4 billion species emerged
on our planet in past eons
but at least 99 of them died out way
before humans spoke the first words
the vast majority of all the different
species that ever existed are so utterly
deleted that they have become part of
the unknown unknown part of the past
lost to us forever
or are they
could we use science and imagination to
glimpse a shadow of the unreachable past
let's start with what we do know
to learn about creatures of the past we
need fossils any sort of remains
preserved from past geological ages
bones or shells impressions or imprints
things preserved in amber
the totality of all fossils on earth is
called the fossil record and it's the
most important window on the past will
ever have
for a dead animal to fossilize a number
of things must go just right
the right environment timing and
conditions
and then the fossil needs to survive for
millions or hundreds of millions of
years and then get back to the surface
and then be discovered before natural
processes dissolve it
so it is kind of a miracle that we have
what we have and know what we know
take the dinosaurs since they were one
of the largest and most successful
groups of animals for some
165 million years and are also a lot of
fun to animate
what were they really like and what are
we missing
in the last 200 years we've found tens
of thousands of fossils from over 1 000
dinosaur species
lately we've entered a golden era of
discovery and about 50 new dinosaur
species are discovered each year
expanding what we know and what we know
that we don't know about them which is
amazing but it also makes us aware of
all the things lost to the past forever
imagine if we took all the animals that
lived in the last 50 million years and
randomly chose 10 000 individuals from 1
000 species to fossilize
think about all the things that would be
missed or that seem too weird to be true
like the giraffe a yellow animal with
brown patterns that looks like a horse
and an antelope had a baby with a long
neck and two tiny hairy horns
how many dinosaur giraffes were there
animals so weird and selected for
ecological niches so specific that
evolution molded their bodies very
absurdly today they might seem made up
to us
we know a lot of species are lost
forever just because of the environment
they lived in
for example lush jungles basically
prevent fossilization as the chances
that an animal will be buried here are
low
countless scavengers of all sizes break
down freshly deceased animals extremely
quickly and the soil is often so acidic
that bones are dissolved
and so fossils of dinosaurs from jungles
are practically non-existent
today half of all known species live in
the few remaining rainforests that only
cover 2 percent of earth's land mass
millions of years ago when dinosaurs
roamed earth jungles covered much more
of the planet
so besides some insects and other small
animals trapped in amber there should be
millions of species that emerged and
vanished without leaving any trace
trapped deep inside the unknown unknown
but just in general biology trips us up
look at your body it's mainly squishy
gooey soft stuff which does not preserve
well what remains the longest are the
crystallized parts of your bones and so
most dinosaur fossils are bones or teeth
usually fragments not entire skeletons
this means that almost all boneless or
shellless animals are practically wiped
from the fossil record
if we take a look at the stunning
diversity of weird animals like worms
jellyfish and slugs alive today we can
only speculate what we are missing
although thankfully many mostly soft and
gooey species also left us an incredible
diversity of shells that tell us an
amazing amount about our past so at
least we have that
still when we think about all the
boneless species that may have existed
in the last half billion years even our
best attempt at imagining them falls
short but it's not like reimagining
something based on its bones is
straightforward and so the way we
envisage what dinosaurs actually looked
like has changed a lot in the last few
years
in the past many illustrations had a
bony minimalistic look with a toothy
grin to signify fierceness and danger
but if we draw today's animals in a
similar way based on their skeletons
just for the fun of it we get the most
bizarre creatures
elephants swans and baboons that look
like monsters right out of nightmares
so similar to animals today we should
imagine dinosaurs with much more soft
tissue fat bellies or chests weird soft
parts like skin flaps lips and gums and
just more pronounced features that would
make them seem like much more pleasant
fellows
some soft features actually leave
distinctive traces on bones that we can
look for in the skeletons of extinct
animals which is where today's animals
with similar features are really helpful
it's a similar story with colors
because we know what the feathers of
living birds look like modern technology
combined with the exceedingly rare
fossils with preserved remains of fuzzy
feathers give us a glimpse of the real
colours of extinct dinosaurs
we know that tiny sinusorptoryx had a
striped tail and its tiny dino buddy
angkianis huxley was white and black
with gorgeous red feathers around its
head
still for the vast majority of really
any ancient extinct species we have no
real clue what colour they were
but we know what modern dinosaurs birds
look like and here we find the most
amazing variety
so some dinosaurs will have tried to
blend into the background while others
might have fielded aggressive colour
schemes to attract mates or to appear
dangerous
some might have had impressive
decorations or colorful beaks
some may have been striped or patent
similarly we don't know that much about
dinosaur behavior although once again we
can draw conclusions from existing
animals for example even apex predators
like lions spend a lot of their time
lying around and cuddling and licking
each other and playing
why would dinosaurs be so different
when we first found the skull of t-rex
with its mighty teeth and probably the
strongest bite of any land animal ever
we imagined a fierce and stupid beast
but modern scanning technology has
revealed the t-rex had a larger
brain-to-body ratio than some earlier
giant meat-eaters and it probably had
very sharp hearing vision and a sense of
smell and was in all likelihood not a
stupid animal
so maybe t-rex was a cuddly fellow that
spent a lot of time playing around or
impressing potential mates when it was
not hungry
likewise while their horns and shields
might have made ceratopsids appear to be
natural-born fighters they were probably
much more than that
based on the behavior of modern animals
and the complex dances some have to go
through to mate maybe their shields were
amazingly colourful maybe it danced for
its mates like many birds do today
how intensely amazing these creatures
must have been
and what a loss it is to us that we
don't get to experience them first hand
what an even greater loss that there is
so much we will never know about them
and even more tragic all the absurd and
beautiful beings that disappeared
without a trace
but such is life
time marches on without any concern for
our feelings and the past expands with
every moment that passes
most wild animals alive today will in
all likelihood not leave fossils behind
and also just disappear forever
we can do something about that though
instead of accelerating the extinction
we are witnessing we could become the
guardians of life and preserve it where
we find it
if possible in the world if not then in
museums movies and in our minds
because as amazing as our imagination is
and as fascinating to think about the
animals that are part of the unknown
unknown it is even better to witness
them in the present
the land that we actually inhabit where
we get to experience life as it happens
there is one more exciting way to
experience dinosaurs though this year
the 12022 human era calendar eons
edition
as always we're adding 10 000 years to
the regular calendar to represent the
human era and include all cultures
around the world but this year we're
expanding the scope beyond humanity to
showcase forgotten animals and plants
from all across the phanerozoic eon like
giant armoured fish scythe lizards or
giant sloths on 12 elaborate pages
witness how multicellular life has
persisted for over half a billion years
surviving asteroid impacts volcanoes and
frozen oceans and of course pandemics
in the end life er finds a way and we
want to celebrate that
you can get the very shiny high quality
limited edition now until we set out and
then never again to support what we do
on this channel to fill the void in your
soul or just to have something beautiful
to look at
as every year we also have bundles and
special calendar deals with some of your
favorite products
[Music]
thank you so much to all of the
thousands of burbs who get the calendar
every year you enable us to create
videos and to publish them for free for
everyone
we wish you a happy year twelve 12 022
me
[Music]